yes
oh
thank you
apologies for starting a few minutes
late here
my name is barbara griffin i'm chair of
the house election law committee we have
a number of public hearings scheduled
this morning that begin
at 9 30 and i see we have a number of
people signed up to speak on bills and i
think we might also have a a clap do we
well welcome to the greater
nashua leadership group for this year
from their chamber welcome to reps hall
um this is the oldest
the longest standing hall in the country
where legislative business is still done
and it's my pleasure to welcome you are
to where we try to get business done of
course with covid the house of
representatives is not regularly meeting
here but when we do every one of these
seats is occupied they are assigned
which is a great help because when you
want to try to find another member you
need to know what seat number they're in
because believe it or not when all these
seats are filled it's pretty hard to see
who is where and if you look down at
your arm you will see a number that's on
the arm there that is the seat number
and you are in a particular section and
at one of our great benefits for being a
legislator here in new hampshire besides
the 100 a year pay is we can get a
license plate that we pay for
and that license plate will have our
seat number on it so when you drive
around and see
a ledgie plate that has some number
combination that's what you're looking
at is an elected member of the
legislature and that is their seat
number
i personally have never put my plate on
my chair
uh on my car not that i wouldn't be
proud to but i will tell you it's also a
very effective way of calling the
speaker's office or the president of the
senate to complain about somebody's
driving
so we hear that a lot in session about
seat number whatever maybe you should
have been driving a little better one
day
um also as we stand here in the hall i
want you to take note of the five
portraits behind us
um a lot of you are here for
what you consider to be and we consider
to be constitutional business and of
course the gentleman on the wall behind
me had a big hand in all of that and one
of those portraits was actually
partially paid for by pennies
anybody know who that might have been
i know one person who does
and what and what particular person
right so that little trivia fact about a
portrait for
with pennies paying for it for abraham
lincoln along with other facts about
what is here in the state house you can
find out by getting the little
self-guided tour book down in our
visitor center
and it's a great way to spend an
afternoon and the state house is of
course open
i have delayed here long enough i would
like to begin our business but before we
do i ask that you join me in a pledge of
allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
that's nice
the first
public hearing this morning is on hb
1484.
the prime sponsor will be here shortly
so in order to introduce the bill to get
it procedurally in front of the
committee one of our own members is
going to introduce us
i recognize representative ross barry to
introduce hb
1484 after he introduces the bill i will
be calling on people to speak who have
signed up if you want to speak on a bill
you're going to fill out a pink card
that's out in the lobby before you come
in the room and i'm going to ask that
your comments we're going to try to keep
them to
maybe four minutes
i might give you a three minute warning
because i want to make sure everybody
has a chance to speak thank you welcome
representative sweeney excuse me whoops
representative just started the day off
like that all right
um thank you madam chairman my name is
representative ross berry i represent
the town of litchfield southern
manchester wars eight and nine i'm here
today to introduce
hb
14 1484 fn as introduced
i am not a sponsor on the bill um the
sponsor i believe will be here shortly
to give a probably more impassioned
speech
this bill allows for a forensic audit of
the 2020 election i did speak with the
sponsor of this bill when he was
drafting it one of the requests that i
made that he put in was that it be
privately financed
because the cost of the windham audit
was rather extreme and to do a similar
procedure
for the
whole state would obviously cost in the
millions of dollars
as i've stated before in the committee
i believe that the number one voter
suppression issue in the state right now
is the lack of faith people have in our
elections and i understand that there
are many people here today to speak in
favor of the bill who probably share
that sentiment and i will let them speak
to that at greater length than me with
that thank you madam chairman since it
is not my bill i will not be taking
questions thank you representative barry
also signed up to speak on this bill is
sandra panic
panic
thank you
thank you for um allowing me to speak
my name is sandra panik and i'm i'm a
retired resident of pelham new hampshire
i'm a gold star mom
and i've been involved in new hampshire
activists and new hampshire voter
integrity group
for the past 12 months
on january 31st i emailed
my local state reps questioning the
integrity
of the tabulating and voting machines
i received a response from our secretary
of state david scanlon the very next day
this was his response
the accu vote operating system used in
new hampshire
for 20 plus years
has a removable memory card
that is programmed prior to each
election
we have always recognized that if access
to the card
is not controlled
it could be tampered with
you may be familiar with a documentary
hacking democracy
which features harry hirsty conducting a
hack of the accu vote memory card
we have worked with mr hirsty at
different levels to make sure our
electronic voting systems are secure
please let me know if you have any
additional questions
this was a clear admission
that the memory cards are hackable
i voted this email that dave scanlan
sent me
to the new hampshire voter integrity
group
i figured they would know what to do
with this information
shortly thereafter
granite grock published david scanlan's
response to me
transparency is key
it has since been scrubbed from the
internet
i have since emailed 144 towns
as a new hampshire state citizen
requesting
and freedom of information act 91a
process
is the right to know
the three questions i posed were how
long do you hold on to the voting
machine memory cards
what is the process
where were the memory cards from the
2020 election sent to
43 towns did not
answer my
a request
94 towns do not have the cards and
already sent them to lhs to be
reprogrammed
erased
only
seven towns
still have the memory cards with the
voter data still intact
nashua responded that i had no right
to this information
derry new hampshire responded that my
requests did not follow
fall under
foia guidelines
of the 43 towns that did respond
to my 91 a
the majority wrote back that they kept
the memory cards
until the recall
time frame passes which is usually five
to ten days after an election
then the memory cards are sent to lhs
the law clearly
states
those memory cards
should not be tampered with for 22
months
lhs is a subsidiary of dominion
china invested
400 million months before our national
election
on october 8th need i go on
the market for election vendors is small
and that competition is fierce
the result is a small network of
companies have near monopolies on
election services
private vendors have long histories of
errors
that affected elections obstructing
politicians
and the public from seeking information
of corruption
suspect foreign influence false
statements of security and business
dishonesty
i also wrote to lhs and received no
response
but these companies are safe keepers
of american democracy
if we can't have transparency
what are they hiding
and why
without transparency
trust in our election has evaporated and
we realize we have already lost our
country
i'm asking you to help us
take back our country
and move forward
for a forensic audit
and safeguard our votes because with
that i have witnessed
we have no confidence
and the machines should be removed as
well thank you for your time thank you
any questions from the committee
i'm not seeing any thank you
um and i i see that
we just had a written statement just so
everybody's aware you can go on the
website and there is a way to submit
a document as to evidence
as to your submission as to your
testimony or evidence and it becomes a
part of the official file
good morning
yeah my name is james wood i live in
merrimack new hampshire
um
i'll start off as i spent 22 years in
the military serving around the world
then i followed on with 20 years working
for a research development company which
explored the government in all different
assets so i've seen different places
around the world
and then i started watching i had just
retired
and i got a little puppy to have
retirement with so i had time on my
hands so i started watching every
hearing that was held across the country
for everything after the 2020 election
and i started to notice something was
very
pretty much problematic about the whole
thing is everything would go on
and you never saw any of the mainstream
media covering any of the hearings
so i'd be like watching and observing
wondering why that information wasn't
getting out to the general public
so then i started to notice that there
were people filming it and it was put on
the youtube or other various
other sources but it was being deleted
immediately after or a day after
why would you do that if you weren't
trying to hide something
for all the things we do in this world
i served around the country
around the world doing different things
for a reason that i thought i was
supporting i went in right after vietnam
i served with guys who got lied to then
and we're lied to now all those years i
thought i was doing something in honor
of the people that were that went before
me i see now has gone up in smoke
i was on the lawn down in dc
on the fifth and i watched what happened
i stood with other veterans there was
three million of us down there five
hundred thousand of us were standing
around talking about what's going on and
they say exactly what i'm going to tell
you
when the political process breaks down
then you're going to have the military
option occur
and we don't want to see that
because any place in the world where you
go where that happens you'll see
the military doesn't ever fix things we
break things that was our job so for
everybody in this room know that this
election can't be put under the table
swept away because we realize there's
something wrong across this country we
can't put our finger on it but we know
it's there
because when things are being taken out
from you can't see it you can't find it
two minutes after it's talked about
there's a problem
thank you
thank you mr wood
also we don't one of the rules of reps
hall is that we don't clap or have any
um outspoken things some of you were
here before and know that uh and part of
that is can you imagine if there were
400 people in here and we were doing
that that would you know it'd make you
know elementary school cafeterias look
like a piece of cake so
um if you really want to show your
pleasure with somebody if you could just
do the jazz hands i think that's what we
allowed to have happen at the last
hearing and i'm seeing some nods yeah i
remember correctly so that's what we'll
do today
good day everybody uh thanks for the
time uh you're giving me to talk uh i'm
actually not technically a new hampshire
resident i'm actually from connecticut
and me and my wife are thinking about
relocating here but it really depends on
what you're going to do
first of all i find it really incredible
that we're here asking you to do
something for us that we're demanding we
want an audit of this 2020 election just
let me make it clear some of the other
previous speakers kind of stole some of
my thunder the bottom line is is that
your grandkids your children and any of
your family members are going to be
living in what you're creating the
bottom line is 22 2020 is a fraudulent
election there is so much evidence of it
it's overwhelming you need to do your
job and look for it stop listening to
jeff silvestro and all his connections
and all those things all anyone has to
do is do a little bit of research spend
the afternoon and start connecting the
dots
we're telling you this is what we want
it's not an option
the constitution of new hampshire as
well as the united states of america
dictates that we have the right to tell
you what we want we want an audit
there's so much evidence it's ridiculous
if you don't do it just remember the
country that you're going to get is the
country that you're helping to create
your grandkids everyone of your family
will have to live in it the
opportunities that you got in this
country to be where you are you're
erasing them for everyone else why
are you american
are you if you are you'll do the right
thing stop making up excuses of why you
can't do it or making up subterfuges or
obscene the the reality that everybody
knows if you're hiding something you're
hiding something end of story anybody
knows this thank you
thank you mr planka if you could
you just said you didn't live here in
new hampshire could you correct your
the infamous question in election as to
also signed up to speak on this bill is
thank you madam chairman and members of
committee uh my name's alvin c and i'm
speaking on behalf of myself
and unfortunately for this bill i think
the train has already left the station
because
mr c can you raise the mic a little bit
you're a little hard for us to see just
tip it up so it's a little more in front
of you thank you
the
unfortunate thing is that the machines
have already been reprogrammed
city elections had
elections last fall
town elections were last spring in fact
the next town elections will occur
before this bill can get through this
legislature so
unfortunately about the only thing that
can be done here is a hand count of
ballots
i don't see any way of doing any other
forensic tests
thank you
also signed up to speak on this is
uh thank you to the committee for
allowing me to speak regina barnes and i
am from hampton i am representing myself
today and people that have my same views
but cannot be here to speak them
so i'm going to do something i don't
normally do i'm going to read something
it's a quote it's from hillsdale college
in premise from last october
16 years ago in 2005 the carter baker
commission on federal election reform
now carter jimmy carter
and baker was a former secretary of
state james baker iii
the carter baker commission on federal
election reform issued a report that
proposed a uniform system of requiring a
voter id in order to vote in u.s
elections
the report also pointed out that
widespread absentee votes
make votes for make vote fraud more
likely voter files contain ineligible
duplicate fictional and deceased voters
a fact easily exploited using absentee
ballots to commit fraud
citizens who vote absentee are more
susceptible to pressure and intimidation
and vote buying schemes are far easier
with citizens vote by mail
so for those of you unaware in july of
two thousand twenty twenty
there was an election commission put
together
i don't really know exactly what it was
called but it was to deal with covid
and how we gonna have the elections with
covid
and it was house bill 1266 which passed
this complete senate it was like a two
to one vote in the house i'm not sure
what that means
and it was signed into law by the
governor this is all when the state
house was closed we couldn't come here
house bill 12
12-66 it was bipartisan and it was
temporary changes made to the state
voting laws for the upcoming 2020
elections only the primary and the
general election
and guess what it was talking about
absentee ballots
and we expanded sending out absentee
ballots
specifically in hampton
we actually i received it at my house it
came in a brown envelope i never vote
absentee i always go to the polls if i'm
in florida i come home and i vote
and they sent me two absentee ballots in
the mail with the now i'm a selectmen in
hampton and i knew we didn't send this
out
and there was a envelope in there with a
return address 101 accounted road which
is the town clerk's office in hampton so
obviously i verify with the town manager
and the town clerk that we did not send
these out
and then later on i find that people in
other towns are getting the same thing
so you know if someone's elderly and
just thinks oh you know and doesn't
think about it
and sends it in my question is
if it gets checked off that so and so
sent the absentee ballot
but they're actually going to vote in
person
and this has happened they go to vote
and they've been told that they've
already voted so you're telling me
there's no fraud in this election
and as far as the millions of dollars it
will count to do a statewide hand count
which is what we will have to do we will
need hundreds of people from every town
people are going to have to get up go
down to the town hall and we're going to
have to complete it as a body as a
community for the whole state
we have the money and i know you guys
may not know specifically but i have
looked at dra financials i have looked
at state park financials the money is
there it just needs to be reappropriated
this does not need to be privately
funded this should come from the state
government because they are the ones
that created the problem
that's all i have to say thank you thank
you
question representative prudhomme
o'brien
thank you very much for coming and for
your testimony
uh these envelopes that you received did
you find out if those were ballots or if
those were ballot requests they were
ballot requests they were absentee
requests so you would be
follow-up
follow-up so
you would have to yourself request an
absentee ballot using those forms that
might have come from a private
organization right but they were at the
actual apps they were the same forms
that the town clerk had okay so the
question is where do they come from and
it's still fraud okay thank you
thank you
the next person i have signed up to
who's calling up his testimony welcome
my printer broke so i'm going to rely
upon my smartphone here
my name is christopher bean and i reside
here in concord
i'm speaking in support of house bill
1484.
i'm a retired professional civil
engineer
and i've always taken my responsibility
to vote seriously
and until the november 2020 election i
was confident that our new hampshire
elections were accurate
live free or die new hampshire
however
based on the hard work of the new
hampshire voter integrity group
and my own research
on serious voting irregularities and
fraud that has been discovered in other
states
with two-thirds of our state using
voting machines associated with
dominion
i'm now concerned about new hampshire
why are many of our election officials
unwilling to provide data
on the election
proving it was fair and honest
if they have nothing to hide
my concerns are that some election
machine
i call them tapes
have not been preserved
what are they hiding
potential inflated eligible voting rules
have not been kept current and accurate
and significantly higher than normal
percentages
of votes
were counted compared to eligible votes
in certain communities
again it's not about the number of votes
based on the support you can see and
have heard from others today
we want the forensic audit to prove that
our votes counted
remember that each of you were elected
to serve the people
if you vote against it i believe you're
covering up a fraudulent election
process that cannot be allowed to
continue
please do the right thing and support a
full forensic audit thank you very much
i'm not seeing any also signed up to
my name's therese grinnell i'm a
registered nurse i live in loudoun new
hampshire i have thrown into the throes
of the political process here in new
hampshire
back in august when i stood up for
medical freedom
since then i've had
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
individuals rally around me
some of them have been involved in the
political process here in new hampshire
for years
every day i wake up and i feel like i'm
peeling an onion back another layer and
it gets stinkier and stinkier as i go
this was a message i got yesterday
good morning i had to tell you i'm
frustrated disgusted and have never been
more aware
and yet distant from the problem we have
in new hampshire
when i learned that the chair here
barbara griffith
and
the chair of the election law committee
hand-picked who she wanted on the
committee
that is a bit of the problem barbara
griffin herself does not believe there
is a fraud and there's voter fraud in
new hampshire
and then you have the three republicans
i'll leave the word out that this person
used that she is controlling joe sweeney
who happened to call me a left-wing
agitator
as the new hampshire is coming out
now
now i'm going to ask you to
consistent hold on
i don't i i miss cornell i am i
what do you have guys
if we have people here that do not care
about voter integrity
we have no hope here
and then fixing the problem in new
hampshire
they're about money
and they're about politics
and we have a bootlegger list
and several of you are on it
and the state of new hampshire is going
to primary you out
we are done this is our children this is
our our veterans this is everything this
country stands for
and if you don't think we're not on to
you you're wrong
we will do it town by town we will do
what canada is doing we will do whatever
it takes to stand up
and if you're a rhino a republican in
name only
and you think you're going to go with
the establishment and not for the people
you won't be in politics long it is a
new day
i have your name on this list and
everyone in new hampshire is going to
have exactly what's going on by the time
i'm done if i don't have any breath left
in me
having us all show up here take time off
from work to let us run around like
chickens with our heads cut off
you knew those memory cards could be
compromised
and you did nothing
each of you took an oath each of you is
liable
and when we have coveted tests in the
liquor store where we're making 12 in
the general fund the state has the money
to bring back our voter integrity and to
do a forensic audit
you can either be on the side of freedom
or you can be on the side of tyranny
you can jump ship and get on the right
side of history right now miss grinnell
you haven't supported testimony on this
bill you continue to go down the wrong
path
and you'll have to face your maker along
with a lot of righteous
constituents in this state
also signed up to speak on this is rusan
chester
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members
i also used to believe in our integrity
of our elections here in new hampshire
and in my town
i remember
everybody running around in 2015 2016
saying there was election fraud
it wasn't from the republican side of
things
we have had a problem with our elections
for years it's it became extremely
obvious in 2020 however we've all agreed
when the republicans are running they
say and they don't win they say there's
election fraud when the democrats run
and they don't win they say there's
election fraud the bottom line is there
is election fraud the machines are part
of the election fraud but there's tons
there's so much so i was doing an
exercise last night with regards to
local government and i found out that
more than 50 percent of our local
um governments have
friends family members or
representatives in local positions
who vote in those voter machines
that's a problem for me
okay that's a problem for me the fact
that because i
recently became involved i found
something about
a bedford town official about a 2020
ballot fiasco running for town moderator
running unopposed
and he made the comment that he does not
work for the people he does not work for
the voters this is who our town
moderator running unopposed
is and part of that is because we are
being we don't have access to who else
is running until after the close of the
of uh everyone's throwing their hat in
the ring
that's when they put it that's when they
put it out there and they say okay this
is who's running i actually went to my
town
clerk on friday at two o'clock asked him
if anyone was running unopposed and she
assured me that was not the case
bottom line is election fraud is a mess
if we want to make
our if we want to bring back integrity
transparency and true
belief in our election cycle and our
state of new hampshire we need to stand
up now
and and to quote uh to quote um
uh
doj folks
just because it it's unethical doesn't
mean it's against the law
that's unacceptable and that was a doj
with regards to not election integrity
but
they are included in that as well
so um
that's pretty much what i have to say
and i'm open for questions
anybody have any questions
i'm seeing none thank you miss chester
i could talk about this for hours so i'm
going to piggyback on what teresa
grinnell said
it's rigged from within
so if we want to just talk about 2020
it's a trifecta of a steel
so in addition to having issues with
machines we already know about that with
sb 43
we know about what took place
with windom
we also have had a problem in this state
for years
and that has to do with people showing
up
buses have been reported coming in from
out of state same-day registrations
don't show an id and they get to vote
every single one of those so let's just
talk about 2016. maggie hassan never won
that's a fact
thousands came back under liberal from
the secretary of state's office what was
done with those people that registered
same day
they are not
domiciled here in new hampshire
nothing's done
now there's bills that are coming up to
you know to put those aside and check
them where have we been this has been
going on for years sweeney you're
this is what happens though you've got
someone that is actually now
representing chuck morse he has a
conflict of interest we we have people
that are rigging this from in governor
sununu signed two laws 1266 being the
most our whole regis our whole general
court was not part of that that was like
24 people after our state house was shut
down that is not representative to open
up absentee ballots to prove the steel
here what we had in 2020. rye is a
perfect example where you knock on
someone's door and there are five votes
from that house and only two people
voted that actually lived there and the
three previous people that owned it that
we need an audit but i know you guys
aren't going to do anything about it
you were in on removing the language
there barbara we know what you did in
regards with the folds on the ballots
you knew it would be a problem you
removed the language you removed the
language when the rest of the house
committee wanted the president's race to
be looked at you removed that language
we know what you did we have it all on
tape we have it all
you put the people back in the room lhs
is owned by dominion you put them back
in the room for the sb-43 audit it was a
fake audit that happened but here we are
this is not going to change anything
this is a wonderful bill we know it
won't happen so now the people have to
take over that's what she said and
that's exactly what has to happen we're
on to all of you
it's it's it's a given here at this
point so i'm really sorry that this is a
wonderful bill and i'm sure that most of
you won't vote for it there has been
problems for years and just so you know
governor sununu's father is the one that
got the machines here in new hampshire
so just so you know that and if you want
to go way back when it was bush against
dole
let's talk about that dole had that
election in manchester he was leading by
nine points nine or ten points when our
polls were really good at that point the
machines got slipped in right then right
and guess what
he took
he took uh
he took manchester
it was never gonna happen bush was never
gonna take manchester and then what
happened oh
john sununu papa sununu became what
chief of staff under bush
it's been rigged for a long time folks
wake up
recognize representative baxter the
prime sponsor of the bill and i'm going
to ask him and our own representative
barry to fill out a pink card before
thank you for having me uh members of
the committee uh hb
uh
1484 i believe i don't have it in front
of me is my bill for a full forensic
audit of new hampshire's 2020 election
results thank you
let me be clear
a majority of this state thinks either
the 2016
or the 2020 election was stolen
the cornerstone of our republic is our
democracy and every voter in this in
this entire state and really the whole
country
deserves nothing less than full
transparency with our elections
this bill would allow every person to
know the truth about 2020 and the 2020
election results in our state
now the main arguments this bill was
it's going to cost millions of dollars
we can't afford this it's a waste of
money so we fixed that
this bill is free let me repeat that
this bill is free for taxpayers because
the bill
the audit is paid for by private
individuals and private non-profits
there is no legitimate argument to be
against
this forensic audit
but you know what
after we fixed the cost
i started to hear a different argument
the argument then became
well
we don't want to look forwards or excuse
me we don't want to look backwards we
i'm sorry if your argument is we don't
want a forensic audit because we might
not like the outcome that the audit
produces that's unacceptable
it doesn't matter what the outcome is
every person in this state deserves to
know what happened in 2020 and to have
no questions at all
all this bill does is provide an avenue
for transparency
it is a common sense bill
and so i urge every single member of
this committee to support this bill and
i'm happy to take any questions at this
time
questions for from committee members
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you madam chair and thank you for
coming here with with your testimony
today
did you
contact the secretary of state's office
with these concerns soon after the
election in that period of time when
recounts are arranged for in a few days
after an election when that and did you
and a second part of the question is did
you find out anything
afterwards that would make you concerned
about it that you uh discussed with them
as well
well thank you representative for the
question this bill first and foremost
isn't about my concern it's about the
concerns of people in this state and
really this whole country
and president donald trump has called
for an audit in all 50 states and the
secretary of the state himself who by
the way is not a trump guy which is fine
but that's just where he comes down on
things he has said that wyndham broke
the law
so we've got a secretary of state that
has said towns operating our elections
have broke the law
of course we should have an audit of our
election so it's not about what i think
or about what i'm doing or that i'm
proposing the bill it's about the people
of this state and they deserve to know
the truth when it comes for 2020. and
also i'd say republicans got elected in
part to fight for election integrity to
make sure every legal vote counts
and then people are wondering what are
elected republicans actually doing to
fight for election integrity in this
state this is a common sense free bill
for taxpayers way to fight for election
integrity and i hope you support it
representative
further questions from the committee
thank you representative baxter thank
you also signed up to speak on this bill
oh all right i'll come back to her mark
rosetti
my name is mark rosetti i'm a state
citizen
of this state
not a resident
a state citizen
the cyber integrity that we're looking
at with this situation
it's a dreamland
it's all false
i went to three or four polling places
and spoke with people who put the the
machines in
and was told that some of them were
connected to routers or modems
they're not supposed to be connected
so
that really bothers me in the past we've
had the last attorney general
at the supreme court before he became
arguing to change the meaning of words
inhabitant
resident
so on and so forth
these games are played behind the backs
of those who should be consenting to
this
it's disgusting
i understand
that there were 134 memory cards erased
that's disgusting
because
by rsa 33a 3a
in
in the new
new hampshire election
procedure manual
it states for elections federal and
state elections balance absentee ballot
applications affidavit envelopes list
and challenge
voters
challenge voter affidavits
should be retained by the city of town
clerk
and the period of retention
is until the contest is settled and all
appeals have expired
or at least 22 months after the election
whichever is longer
for that reason and that reason only
this election should be audited there's
no question about it
it's totally illegal and heads should
roll
those who allow
those memory cards
to be erased
it's it's disgusting
we don't our redress or grievance has
gone away in this state
it's it's
it's
it puts me beside myself now to go to an
election
i can go to a liquor store and i'm 63
years old and they asked me for an id
but when i went to vote in atkinson in
the town that i'm from
i wasn't asked for an id
i understand immigration's flying people
in
to p's international airport are these
people going to be able to vote they're
not even domiciled here or have proof of
domicile or residents or proof that they
are inhabitants
our elections are being stolen every
which way but loose
we're going to end up
we're going to end up with this being
the comitat
which is russia
we're not going to end up having a free
country anymore
so
and and one last thing
we have a third party
company
that is responsible for counting our
votes
and responsible for the election
machines
lhs
they are not responsible to any of you
or any of us
they're a private company
that's disgusting
we need to go back to paper ballots as
soon as this audit is done
i'm not going to say please
do this audit
i'm going to instruct my magistrates
to do this audit
especially when i find out that it's not
coming out of public funds
it's being paid for privately
thank you
also signed up to speak
all right it was this committee's
responsibility to to ensure an accurate
option just to be sure it's marilyn todd
oh sorry because people are listening
yeah yeah maryland todd nashville new
hampshire thank you all right so it was
this committee's responsibility to
ensure an accurate audit here's the
things that went wrong the cameras went
out four extra boxes showed up than what
wyndham had originally known about or
sent out three verified voting auditors
one of them passed out didn't even
answer our questions and that was one of
the ones selected
you all knew about foldgate and as an
auditor i'm going to speak to you
coming from a professional stance you're
going to tell me that a paper fold
caused four republicans to gain 300
around exactly 300
votes from the hand count to the machine
count and then the leading democrat lost
99 those numbers that's why i started
this i didn't even know what a house rep
was a year ago this month i didn't know
what a house rep was i didn't know what
a senator was but i knew when i saw that
four republicans were shorted 300 votes
each
and the leading democrat gain 99 as an
auditor that's a problem those are two
even numbers and a paper fold is
it's just too crazy it's too it doesn't
make sense for a paper fold to do that
i also want to say that you know we have
on live video
that harry hirsty deleted our memory
cards every i have evidence
of three elections
all with the same exact uh memory cards
three elections have been wiped so far
three
the state of new hampshire has broken
the law three different times we have we
have attorneys coming into new hampshire
we have documentaries being made we have
evidence of this all
so do the right thing because no matter
what this is all going to be exposed and
it's going to keep being exposed and i'm
not none of us here are going to stop
until it's done and it's 9 30 in the
morning and that's why this whole house
isn't full because when i tell you we
have a lot of support when i started
this group a year ago
it was embarrassing to talk about
election fraud i'm telling you right now
i will scream it from the mountaintops
and so will everybody else in this room
we deserve a free audit we just we
deserve a free and fair audit my son
deserves to vote if he wants to vote and
know that his vote counts
our i told you guys when i first started
this last year don't make us choose our
children's future don't make us pick our
children's future because they're always
going to win
and we deserve this and you guys have
made way too many mistakes allowing lhs
like i said to you guys in the last
meeting
as an auditor as a forensic auditor that
is my job title if i ever gave the irs
of my
directions on my client on how to audit
them from my client
we would all go to jail we would all go
to jail if i erased my client's pos
system i would go to jail
i am an auditor too and i know how this
works and like i said last time the
whole audit was based on just because
it's unethical doesn't make it a
criminal violation they knew it was
unethical harry hirsty you guys spent
3.1 million dollars
in
2016-2017 somewhere around there harry
hirsty
literally was paid over a quarter of a
million of that
already he's already been in our
machines for
for election security
why are we having people that have
already been in our machines audit i
would be i would go to jail for that as
well i would go to jail if if i did your
bookkeeping and i did your audit i would
go to jail
so why with our most sacred right are we
not protecting it more than money how
does that make sense
and i'm not going to stop and none of us
are going to stop and we're going to
keep waking people up and that's what
we're going to do because i'm telling
you right now we have a full team coming
to new hampshire guys we have a full
team and i promise you that it's just
going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and you guys can either join us
and show that you that this isn't
because of you or you can um or or you
guys can you guys will be voted out i
mean we've already proved that we can do
this we've already proved that if if
someone doesn't do what they're supposed
to do we will vote them out and we will
spend every waking moment doing that
because for my children i will climb
mountains i will move them i will do
whatever i need to do to make sure my
children are free
also signed up to speak
um sheila tripodi
good morning excuse me my name is sheila
tripode and i come from bridgewater
new hampshire
i do not believe this is about voter
integrity this is not about democrat
this is not about republican this is not
about
anything but personal
integrity
people
who are truthful
you have been put in the positions that
you are put in for a reason and that is
to represent
you can leave today and we're probably
history
you can't walk away from your personal
integrity and i am asking you and urging
you
to exercise
the trust that we have put in you
to do the right thing
thank you
thank you good morning thank you for
having me here my name is steve lataris
i'm a citizen
of the state of new hampshire and
america
i have served the military in three
different branches i'm a retired federal
agent
i have been in wartime i've been in
peacetime i've served approximately 30
years
i've been all over the world
i know what democracy is i fought for it
my friends and colleagues were killed
i'm concerned where we are going
america is on the precipice of collapse
we the people
as you heard
representative baxter this is a free
audit
if this is free
there's really no
you know fiduciary
burden on the state
so i'm asking each and every
representative
for the continuance of our free and fair
elections that you do a house audit a
forensic audit
this last election there's no question
there is a plethora and i don't want to
get into
that that side issue but there's a
plethora of evidence
that this was a stolen election there's
no question the videos are out there
we're all well read
i've served the front lines i'm a former
presidential security as well i know
what is happening to this nation
just because a certain
individual ran for politics
but we know there's a history going back
dominion anything let me tell you
something anything is hackable
i have a top secret clearance i did some
of the most highest secrets for this
government
dominion can be hacked anything can be
hacked there are some very brilliant
actors in in communists and spies out
there
that
countries including our own
unfortunately because we have been
infiltrated by trojan horses
we need fear
and honest elections
the constitution wants it the bill of
rights want it
all us americans want it we demand it
i will die fighting for this nation as a
civilian right now
i will give my last breath and my last
ounce of blood i will not allow this
nation to be stolen
and i demand accountability and i demand
forensic audit you got to remember
you all work for us
and you all know that i'm not here to
counsel you i'm not here to
you know mark a ridicule
but it is overwhelming nationwide
americans want accountability and we
demand justice and we demand
a forensic audit thank you
thank you any questions
um
secretary scanlon did you want to speak
and thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm david scanlon
after you saying secretary of state
um
the great thing about new hampshire
elections are that they're decentralized
and that we rely on thousands of locally
elected officials to conduct our
elections it's a very very human process
and there are individual failures that
take place and
we see that in windham and we see that
in bedford those have been very public
examples
the system is not perfect there are
mistakes that are made
and when they are people are held
accountable
but that failure
at an individual level does not
translate into some type of a major
conspiracy
um
or
you know collusion to
uh
do something different with the actual
election results i have complete
confidence
in the way new hampshire runs its
elections
i believe that the results are accurate
they they reflect who should be placed
in office sir all right um
jazz hands are okay i'm putting up with
what i consider to be very disrespectful
hands down um jazz hand and one of the
reasons we have the rule in reps hall
about how we conduct ourselves is
because each one of you is entitled to
speak and to have us listen regardless
of what we say and whether or not we
agree with it so
i am giving secretary scanlan the
courtesy of speaking to this please keep
your response silent
so we can continue with the hearing this
morning and also get on to our other
bills and thank you very much continue
the point is that because we're
decentralized and we have all of those
volunteers average people
in the state of new hampshire
all citizens
all dedicated
and i believe they all have integrity
would know if there was something
going on
with our elections
in in the form of some type of
conspiracy they would be here at a
meeting like this if that's what they
believed
but they're not
and i think if you reach out and talk to
those local election officials
they also would express the confidence
that they have in that process
now are there ways that we can be more
transparent
certainly and i think we have major
training issues that we have to deal
with with local election officials we
have to do a better job
communicating with the general public
and the voters so that they understand
what that process is
and all of the checks and balances that
are in place
to make sure that our elections are
accurate and fair
in terms of this particular bill
calling for a statewide audit
at a time when we are gearing up for the
2022 election cycle
would be incredibly difficult to do
we'd have the
you know the the managing the ballots
from the last election uh being
you know to participate in an audit
while we're trying to get everything
ready for the 2022 election
frankly i haven't heard anything here
today in the form of evidence that shows
that there was something
wrong uh
on a larger scale that we really need to
look into so
again i can only express my faith
in our election process uh
you know and uh
i'll end there madam chair i'd be happy
to answer any questions terry scanlon um
speaker i have signed up is brian
richardson
before mr richardson gets to the mic as
you all know you can sign up online to
indicate your position on a bill that
closes in the morning of the hearing
and in regards to 1484 we had 187 people
signed up in support and 292 signed up
opposed welcome mr richardson thank you
brian richardson alexandria
um i'm going to be short and sweet here
um but we uh we pride ourselves in the
fact that we are the first and first in
the nation primary
well if we uh if we want to maintain
that how can we continue with
this as as
so many people know that this uh this
last election and others may very well
have been
have been fraudulent
if we don't have free and fair elections
folks what do we have
if we if we cannot if we cannot
all agree that we that we
and believe that we have free and fair
elections
what do we have where do we go from here
folks i we we
we have to be transparent if we can't be
transparent then then
what what avenue does do the populace
have after that
thank you
thank you and with that testimony thank
you everybody for coming on this
the public hearing on 1484 and our next
bill is 1473
which is also in regards to a forensic
audit this is of the november 2020
election results in merrimack county for
president governor and united states
senate um and with us here to
introduce the legislation is the prime
thank you madam chair and uh committee
for the record state rep pattabrami
rockingham 19
town of stratham
madam chair
the citizens of new hampshire would
welcome
and be well served if a more complete
forensic audit
of our election process was conducted
we recommend utilizing ballots from the
last general election
because those are only ballots that we
can look at
the cards are wiped out after 22
months so
if we don't
the from prior elections those those
ballots don't exist
those cards don't exist from the
machines
it is clear that this audit can raise
what is currently very low voter
confidence
you will hear
in in testimony from others why this
bill is very focused
with the detailed methodology laid out
in the language of the bill
it is up to us
as legislators to hear the voices of the
people
we in new hampshire have never had this
type of thorough audit
of our election process done
it is probably
long time overdue
the purpose of of house bill 1473
is to use a single county and we chose
merrimack
not
there anything special about merrimack
but it's a medium-sized county pretty
much that's why we picked merrimack
to be audited
the audit would be limited to
presidential gubernatorial and u.s
senate race races to be utilized as the
test races
the audit will be conducted within
with a
impartial never-before-use third party
who can provide an evaluation of the new
hampshire process and tools
should there be a large enough gap in
the audit results in merrimack
the balance of the state would be
audited
what makes the audit approach prescribed
in this bill unique
is that it will not include stakeholders
just like audits
conducted by cpa firms for publicly
that do
this not only is best practice but it
removes any potential concerns that the
audit was biased in any way
the audit will be
visible to the public with the aid of
volunteers from both parties
the audit team will document and
identify process gaps detail areas of
vulnerability and report on
inconsistency and election results
they will make recommendations on their
findings
to to be acted upon by this legislature
again the intent
of the effort is to improve election
processes
as needed
we're not doing any for
gone conclusions
if we're we're doing an audit just to
see like any other company would like a
company would do
to see if there's any improvements that
could could help us out
this bill in no way attempts to change
the 2020
election results this is a
forward-looking bill designed to boost
voter confidence
you have all heard much testimony from
on
and why an audit is needed you will hear
continued testimony on why i'm sure
however you will also hear testimony on
independent citizen audit efforts
that have been conducted
i will once again leave it to
brenda town
for whom i filed this bill for
to walk you through the specifics of the
bill
however my contribution to the bill
was my suggestion to set up an election
audit fund
which is section 10 of the bill which is
on page 3 lines 14 to 23.
those who supported the audit
idea suggested that gifts grants and
donations can be raised to help pay for
the audit
being a member of the ways and means
committee i was aware
that there is a way to properly have the
state accept private money the language
of this section is what is generally
utilized the key language and i'll quote
it says there is established in the
state treasury an election audit fund
which shall be administered by the
secretary of state
if this was an agricultural fund
it would say which should be
administered by the commissioner of
agriculture so this
the reason the secretary of state's
involved because this is election uh
election bill
uh election fund
the bill does does ask for an
appropriation though of 150 000 to seed
the fund which i am sure the finance
committee will weigh in on if this bill
passes
madam chair
i know your committee will give full
consideration to this bill
once again i must return to my ways and
means committee
where we're
we're doing work sessions and executing
bills
so i will uh i will
so please if you can allow miss uh town
to alert us to answer your your
questions
however i will take any questions that
relate to the the fund that we're
talking about because that's an area i'm
very familiar with
does anybody have any questions
representative terozian
thank you madam chair thank you the
member for taking my question
so in that section you just referenced
you you show us some of 150 000
do you think this audit can be done for
that or is that just a down payment on
it
that that will pay for a part of it
i think that's why we're we're creating
the fund for other donations
so
do you have an estimate of what you
think it would cost to do this i don't
i don't
perhaps
this town does
thank you
thank you representative vibrami also
signed up to speak on this as
representatives susan holmel up from
yes madam chair thank you for listening
to testimony and thank you to the
members for uh hearing closer to the mic
because it's got to get picked up by the
live stream thank you
better thank you for the members for
listening today to testimony i'm
representative sue hamala hamola i
represent hollis
the purpose of this testimony is to
provide support for hb 1473 authorizing
a phrasing forensic audit of the
november 3rd 2020 election results for
merrimack county
following the election a constituent
with a background in data analysis
contacted me regarding preliminary vote
analysis he did for select towns across
new hampshire
he detected anomalies in the data and
brought those to the attention of mr bud
fitch
legal counsel for the secretary of
state's office mr fitch informed him
that the analysis method he performed
was not rigorous enough to rate further
action on the matter
the constituent then redid the analysis
with the more thorough method used
utilizing publicly available vote totals
from 2020 he compared those with the
2016 general election results
he performed an analysis of every town
across new hampshire
interestingly this data revealed an
issue with the windham state rep race
before the infra before that information
was even publicly
available
or publicly discussed
this data highlighted statistical
anomalies in multiple towns which showed
shifts in the federal ticket results
when compared with the historically
expected results of the state house race
results for example statistical
anomalies occurred in some select towns
in hillsborough county
such as litchfield lindenborough nashua
and hudson
and in rockingham county it occurred in
such places as northampton which showed
an even bigger deviation from the
historically typical vote share
in merrimack county statistical
anomalies presented themselves in some
locations such as concord ward 8 and
newberry
please note this is not a complete
listing it's just some examples where
anomalies are noted
in addition to this data another
analysis was done which compared vote
totals of towns that did and did not use
the die bold slash dominion machine
counting devices
in towns and districts that did not use
diebold machines the republican
presidential candidate's overall vote
share was 2.8 percent less than the
local new hampshire state house
republican candidates
in locations that did use die bold
machines the republican presidential
candidate's overall vote share was 6.4
percent less than local new hampshire
state house republican candidates
this results in an overall difference of
3.6 percent and that means that in
places where dibold machines were used
there is a more than double percentage
of under voting
please note this vote data this vote
count data analysis in each town in no
way suggests malfeasance
however given the historically expected
vote deviation it did suggest that a
closer examination was warranted
on december 3rd i sent a letter to
chairman cook of the ballot law
commission regarding the vote analysis i
sent this letter to the ballot law
commission because this is where i was
advised to send the letter
after i spoke to mr fitch at length
about the matter
a copy of the letter was also sent to
the offices of the secretary of state
and the governor
a copy of this letter has also been
emailed to you all individually
after receiving no response from the
ballot law commission the secretary of
state or the governor's office i sent a
follow-up email on december 23rd
i received a reply from the ballot law
chairman mr cook the following day
december 24th with his assurances that
he would speak to the secretary of
state's office
on january 14 2021 i received his reply
which stated that the ballot law
commission did not have the jurisdiction
to review the matter further
a copy the emails between myself and the
ballot law commission have also been
emailed to you individually
throughout my request for an audit of
some new hampshire towns i have
regularly emphasized that i make no
assertion of election malfeasance
it is quite possible that in one of the
most hotly contested elections in recent
memory the voters of new hampshire did
choose to be the only state in the
country to completely flip its state
legislative majority while
simultaneously vote for the opposing
political party candidates in all
federal races
with the cre that i truly am not being
sarcastic with the craziness of 2020 we
know that anything's possible
having said that is clear that over this
past year voter confidence has been
strained and given the amount of energy
and pride we infuse into our state
election process this lack of confidence
represents something quite disheartening
especially if we leave it unchecked
i've heard some election officials say
that it's time to move forward and not
backward as we close the chapter on the
november 3rd 2020 election
it does not take much effort to discover
that the uneasiness many new hampshire
voters have felt about this past
election is still relevant and important
issue and voter confidence has been
further shaken by our collective apathy
over this past year
until we properly examine a sampling of
the anomalous vote data we know exists
lack of public confidence and vote
integrity will continue to cast out over
all future elections which would really
be heartbreaking
i support hb 1473 because it casts a
wide enough net by which to properly
audit the november 3rd 2020 election
results and it will enable us to restore
public confidence in our election
process going forward
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you representative any questions for the
representative thank you seeing none
thank you for coming and staying this
morning
brenda towne has also signed up to speak
good morning everybody and thank you
very much committee and thank you chair
for hearing me today my name is brenda
towne i'm becoming a regular here and uh
appreciate the opportunity to talk to
you
i live in stratham i'm a daughter of a
u.s marine a mother of four including
yeah
is that better
okay
um
a mother of four including three
military um sons a grandmother of eight
and i'm a businesswoman and i'm part of
this large team here that's been working
together to do a citizen's audit based
on our concerns over the 2020 election
we have 8 000 people participating in
various forms across multiple platforms
and we've executed over 243 foia
requests in order to do the work that
we're doing
in 2020 we experience some really
unusual things in new hampshire and so
what i want to do is talk about two
things
because hb
1473 has really two asks of this
committee
the first ask is in regards to
conducting a forensic audit of a test
case which is merrimack we're asking you
to evaluate some of the evidence you're
hearing today on the necessity of that
audit
the second thing we're asking you is to
do the audit in a very prescribed way
there is a lot of fallout from our
windham audit in a lot of learnings and
so we carried them forward into this
bill so i'm going to touch on those two
parts
so the first thing what happened in 2020
that made us all think
we needed to kind of look into this
beyond the fact that we have not ever as
a as a state conducted
an audit of our election practices which
is as pat mentioned is really unusual
any large business that has outside
stakeholders uses third-party audit so
that they can commit to those
stakeholders that the results are
accurate and we do not have that
practice and so this is our opportunity
to do it
in 2020 we had
255 percent increase in our absentee
ballots
that is a third of all the ballots cast
in 2020 were absentee this was an
anomaly for us again covet happened but
never in our history did we have over
nine percent absentee ballots
across the state we had some really
unusual things happen too
so i'm going to isolate two counties in
rockingham the county ballots grew one
percent in 2012 from the prior election
in 2016
from the prior election but miraculously
they grew 13
in 2020 in one of the two parties grew
by 25 percent now what makes that
unusual is that the population in
rockingham grew two percent
so how in the world would that happen
makes you scratch your head it's on that
list of the things that make you go hmm
right
let's talk about hillsborough very
similarly um they had flat ballots in
a decline in 2016
but they grew 12 percent overall in 2020
and 23
uh voter growth in a single party in
that election while the population grew
1.7
something doesn't make sense and that is
why
we really need to focus on the data and
the details and that's why we're asking
your help here
so let's just talk a little bit about
the foundations of our election process
you've heard people talk about our
machines
as a state we have
given the responsibility of managing our
election process through the machines to
a single company named lhs
lhs is the is the single focus of the
machine
memory card programming as well as any
updates and maintenance through our
four-year requests we have found that
most state clerks
sorry town clerks have had lhas come in
perform
maintenance on their machines no one
signed the forms no one said what
they've done and they've sent their
cards back post the election immediately
to lhs for reprogramming and
anticipation of the next election as
you've heard this is in violation of
federal law by not maintaining the data
for 22 months
major problem
the second thing about the machines is
that they are hackable again mentioned
by other people giving testimony as well
as in a letter from our own secretary of
state the machines are vulnerable
what makes it even more disconcerting is
that we have it documented and splashed
across the country in documentaries
where our lhs machines are the focal
point you can see them hacking it
on the big rig and hacking democracy so
it's a big problem for us
where the rubber hits the road and up to
this point in time most everything i can
tell you is anecdotal it really becomes
data driven when i tell you about our
canvas
this fearless group of people went out
and canvassed multiple towns we knocked
on
almost a thousand doors we reached about
half of the people and what we found is
about 13 to 15 percent of the votes cast
were not cast by the voters at those
homes we have and again we can mention
these cases you've heard them
people that live in the residence didn't
vote had absentee ballots cast on their
behalf we have addresses that do not
exist we have people who've gone in and
voted in person who had absentee ballots
cast for them these have generated
affidavits in these affidavits sit in
front of the attorney general they were
sent to him hard copy he has them as a
monday electronic copy they were served
as of saturday we continue to canvas and
bring forward information but this is
hard data that is relevant to where we
are today and the need for this
information
so let me talk a little bit about windom
and why we have
actually put the procedure of how we'd
like this audit conducted you know what
we saw we had windom in the spotlight
you guys saw the boxes being rolled out
boxes being open you could reach in we
also had
a very public
issue where we hired a third party
auditor who has been well known to us
his name is harry hirsty
harry hirsty was the focal point for
instructing on the machine audit
we have him on video instructing the
reset of the cards to pre-election
and we also have him instructing making
no
copy of the existing memory cards this
reset our memory cards to pre-election
i also have which i will
provide to you an affidavit signed by
harry hirsty when he was in a court
appearance in wisconsin
in his affidavit he states that the
memory cards can be hacked and that once
they are reset the hack is removed so we
have his signed affidavit and we have
him on tape
um performing that exact maneuver within
our windham art this is incredibly
disconcerting to the people in the room
and the people that are concerned about
election integrity so we've been very
prescriptive we have asked let's do a
sample to find out what's going on in
new hampshire
we've asked to go into merrimack and do
a three race
audit using a third party with
participation both from the towns as
well as a member of the house a member
of the senate and a third party
consultant to help them with technical
questions
to us
nothing short of a detailed forensic
audit with an impartial third party will
satisfy our concern
over the condition of the election
process here in new hampshire and we are
asking you asking you to step forward
and help us conduct this
my father was a marine
my sons serve
and they are willing to shed their blood
for this country
and i believe that our ballots are what
they fight for if we would audit banks
we should be auditing these ballots
and i thank you for your consideration
and i'll be glad to take your questions
thank you miss town committee have any
questions representative lane
thank you we
we asked and i don't recall the answer
what towns did you conduct these audits
in the canvas
the campus yes we canvassed waterville
and rye as our first two towns and we're
have actually canvases going on in other
towns as well
questions from the committee
thank you miss town thank you
hi marilyn todd nashville new hampshire
so i just want to say when scanlan got
up to speak i've sent so in our audit
there was federal as as brenda just went
over there was federal laws that were
broken and there were state laws that
were broken we will be filing lawsuits
for both
and a class auction so we're filing
three lawsuits against the state of new
hampshire but we're hoping we don't have
to
because i need to go back to work i have
three kids i have spent the last year
auditing the state
and i don't know what it's going to take
for me
for for us
to show you that we're not going to give
up
and
you know
the last time i talked about what was
wrong with wyndham
so
but but you guys have an opportunity to
make that right you guys have an
opportunity to do what's right for this
country and and to do what's right for
us because i'm not going back to work i
made that promise at the audit to
um
chief investigator dick tracy and i told
him i will not be going back to work
until new hampshire gets a free audit
and i promise you i won't and my boss
really needs me right now it's tax
season so i need to go back to work but
i'm not going to until we get an audit
and i'm not going to stop waking people
up and i'm not going to i have
documentaries being made i have
documentaries being made and a lot of
them involve you guys and if you guys
want to keep sitting on the spotlight
new hampshire we have a lot we have
documentaries being made we have
lawsuits being filed and we have
uh deputy the chief deputy bud fitch
said that he
that we were we have this in writing we
have we have a whistleblower
town clerk we have a whistleblower town
clerk
just so you guys know i'm sure you i
don't know if you guys saw the interview
or not but there is
and and bud fitch literally writes in an
email that you don't have to keep the
memory cards it doesn't get much more
clear than that that is
a federal violation it's a federal
violation it's a state violation why
would you not keep those memory cards
when you know that they can be hacked i
also have an email from from scanlan
admitting that the the the memories
cards can be hacked so why would you not
keep a memory card
that can be hacked
does that make any sense if you guys put
your money if this was your money would
you audit it and i know damn well you
guys would audit this if this was your
money so i'm asking you to do all of us
a favor here because we breathe and live
these elections and and like i said a
lot of us are working
there's people that work
10 hours a day and then come home and do
a bunch of data entry for new hampshire
voter integrity these people are done
with it and and
the only reason why they're not here
today is because it because it's a work
day so i'm asking you let us get our
lives back because we're just going to
keep waking more and more and more
people up and it's not going to stop and
do the right thing
you guys all have kids don't you want
them to vote don't you want to ensure
their their their future
if and scanlan needs to be the first
person to go because i have a bunch of
evidence i don't mind if you point at me
i don't want you pointing it out of the
car
okay he's not here anymore oh okay i
didn't even notice i just know he was
sitting in that direction
[Laughter]
all right you can point go back you can
do it he's not here anymore he laughed
after i confronted him about his lie
just so you know i did confront him
about his lie and he left so
the
you have dean um so the moral of the
story is
please either there's only two options
get rid of the machines or give us a
real audit
like
there's two bills those are the only two
options and that's only fair and u.s
have to agree with that this is our most
sacred right i've fought for this
country my husband's fought for this
country my grandfathers came on the
mayflower and and my grandfather served
in the american revolution that must
mean something we're all fighters in
this room and we're not going to give up
give us back our give us back our state
and and give us back our sanity so
means or get rid of or give us an audit
if you don't do one of the two that
any questions for miss todd
good morning my name is elaine plant and
i'm a dover resident
i am also can you get a little closer to
the mike yes elaine plant from dover and
also first time um being in a meeting
like today
and also admittedly having been a lazy
citizen most of my life but
that has changed because of what i've
had to a chance to witness for myself
and that recently with voter
registration and the absentee ballots i
believe there are questions that need
answers in both of those areas
a close friend of mine acquired the
voter registration list from her town
on that list were three people
registered at her own home address not
her family who had not lived there in
well excess of 10 years and there were
many examples like that that she found
this prompted me to get my town's voter
registration list and when i went to my
clerk's office i was denied access as
were several friends trying to access
the voter list from their towns as well
um that is a problem as this is public
information so we ended up calling the
state and we're given access to those
lists and it begs the question of why we
did why were we denied access in the
first place and where is the
transparency and why were we being
denied
a friend and i vetted the official
checklist of the
state general election of 11-3 2020
including the same-day registration with
the voter registration list for that
town we observed double votes people
voting with no address and no id people
on the voter list but listed again on
the write in page write in pages with 25
to 50 names on them per ward and per
letter
signatures missing by the monitors
witnessing the pages
that voter roll had not been updated in
10 years the volunteers at these
election sites can't be the ones
responsible for making sure everything
is accurate from what i saw i do not
have great confidence in the election
process
i had the opportunity to canvas in the
rye area in new hampshire in october of
2021 with nine other people for a few
hours while knocking on doors i
discovered from the current residents
that two others registered at that
address no longer lived there at another
address a person registered on the list
had main license plates
in early
october
of 2021 i went to the clerk to obtain
absentee ballots for myself and my
husband
i could not leave with my husband's
ballot as he was not with me so the
clerk had to mail it i asked about
timelines to be sure that we'd receive
it before traveling
the clerk
stuffed sealed and put the ballot in
outgoing mail while i watched her to
allay any fear of not getting it timely
two weeks later
still no ballot my husband had to go
into the clerk he had to sign off on a
paper that he had not received it and
get another ballot to vote
so the disappearing ballot out there was
for anybody else to vote with
my daughter not living with us traveling
for a living requested her absentee
ballot and never received hers as a
result she was denied the opportunity to
vote in the 2020 election where did her
missing ballot go
i support the hb 1473 because in my
little world i have seen this much
irregularity and i need effort through
investigation to restore my confidence
in the election process
and then this was not written but
because i've learned a lot here this
morning just from the others
and
i was a little bit shocked at what came
out of mr secretary of state scanlon's
mouth saying that he feels secure that
if there were issues happening we'd know
it
we have the opportunity
to not go upon feelings we have the
opportunity to do an investigation and
make all those voices who feel that it
is not secure secure
and then i learned another thing this
morning me being nervous as a first-time
voice and i heard other first-time
voices i think we're going to have
a windfall of first-time voices now
speaking up because they
everybody has questions and they're
having their own experiences and they're
hearing all these other people thank you
thank you any questions from committee
members
seeing none also
signed up to speak is michael ivanovic
from
thank you i'm actually
yes
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members
with any problem
we need to help find a solution
because the bottom line is you've heard
lots and lots of testimony and even um
secretary of state scanlan said oh yeah
windham was a problem bedford was a
problem but those are outliers well
that's the same thing that harry hershey
said when he did the winding we had a
perfect storm
when do
coincidence become unlikely
when does that happen after the fifth
coincidence after the 23rd coincidence
after the 153 coincidence the bottom
line here folks is that
we don't believe that our elections have
integrity
we have some problems
and i can honestly say i think covert 19
helped helped
help expose that
because we had a lot of time on our
hands and we were watching closely
number one number two the absentee the
absentee ballot issue was huge in 2020.
as a matter of fact in bedford the
absentee ballots went up almost 50
percent
in the 2020 election
now i can tell you i know for a fact
some of that is bedford new hampshire
has a lot of assisted living
and
nursing home
type of placements
our law our election law allows
all those residents to ask through the
um
division
through the person the executive
director they can request an absentee
ballot via
the executive director they get the
absentee ballot
they fill out their absentee ballot
and the executive director now this is
the only time
that this is not controlled
by our town clerk or any other kind of
elective official
the executive director is allowed to
bring those ballots and they
they actually sign saying i know for a
now we've heard we've heard secretary of
state scanlan say i trust i trust that
our elections don't we have some
problems well if we have some problems
how are we going to fix them unless we
know exactly what they are that's what a
forensic audit will do for us it'll
provide the the learning opportunity to
say this is what we've done wrong and
this is what we need to change
the you we are i feel very comfortable
that the machines are problem they've
always been a problem you can hack in
anything if you can hack into the
department of defense you can hack into
lhs voting machines just saying
um
bottom line is is that the machines are
a problem but there are hundreds of
other
problems and outliers
when do a hundred problems become
something more than a coincidence
thank you
thank you miss chester also signed up to
so i'm actually going to speak to um i
wasn't going to speak on this but i am
because of what
secretary of state recent secretary of
state david scanlan said so if
everything is you know we do a good job
in new hampshire then why would
former secretary of state bill gardner
who has been the secretary of state for
decades
send an 11-page letter
which is
damning
basically to the windham town officials
saying and i'm just going to quote one
paragraph in here
wyndham's election night results were
not just imprecise
they were fundamentally flawed for an
exhaustive review please see the report
of the forensic audit team
but simply put town election officials
cut corners
some of those shortcuts
created errors such as using an
uncalibrated folding machine
which were unintentional and perhaps
unforeseeable but ultimately resulted in
ballots not being accurately counted
other errors such as the use of only six
test
test ballots
instead
of the recommended 50
ignored legal obligations and are of
continuing concern as they are
indicative of an election that was not
executed to the standard of the law or
expectations of voters
this is an 11 page letter you should all
have a copy of that do you
you do wonderful
that alone
demands an audit
i don't you know if it's not going to be
the whole state then merrimack county
right there
pick a town
that's all we need is a town rockingham
county had really lots of problems so if
you want to talk about rye
waterville valley hmm who owns
waterville valley isn't there a ski area
there yeah we all know who that's uh
connected with as well as look at derry
how about milford milford folds just so
you know milford overvotes i believe
that a state rep that was a republican
actually missed his missed his calling
here because of that look at the
overvotes of milford it's unbelievable
there's too many and actually a democrat
got that seat
but when we tried to look at auditing
just on an outside version
milford's town tapes were packaged in
the ballots that were sent to the
secretary of state and we didn't have
access to those tapes which is against
the law we can go on and on and on so
for him to stand up there and say oh
well we had some problems bedford uh you
know windham what about merrimack new
hampshire want to talk about those
problems at about 5 p.m or 6 p.m over a
thousand ballots came in
that weren't there that were supposedly
just found
that's been reported all of these things
too when he says that have been reported
to the ag i reported a ton of stuff from
rye my husband was a poll watcher i was
a poll watcher i reported it to the new
hampshire gop fraud i reported all of
this kind of stuff i had people that
were from california with a license
voting and i'm challenging it but you
have to stay like you know 12 feet away
everybody's all concerned about a mask
they don't really care about anything
so all of these things were reported and
have been reported for years
the busloads of people coming in so for
us to act like nothing's just been done
that's the problem nothing's been done
nothing's been investigated so this is
this is the ag and this goes back this
isn't just gordon mcdonald which is now
the chief justice of the new hampshire
supreme court that was
put in there
by governor sununu so
we're talking about being rigged from
within these aren't made up things
all of the reports to the ag all of the
reports the secretary of state have
fallen on deaf ears look at project
veritas they had to uncover some of the
stuff and it's like a deer in headlights
with bill gardner so
you know god bless all the time but it's
very he gave us this gift this 11 page
document that you all received was his
parting gift to us
for not doing stuff for a very long time
but that parting diff is the reason why
that you need to audit with an
independent party i don't care what it
is pick five towns
good afternoon madam chair and
committee members
my name is melody fitz i reside in
laconia new hampshire which is one of
the 11 towns of belknap county
i am a registered nurse of 41 years five
of those which i did quality and
utilization review
so i know what
integrity looks like
i come from a strong family background
that takes voting and legislative
process seriously in fact my great
grandfather served in the vermont house
of representatives
my journey that leads me to join new
hampshire
boater integrity group and stand before
you today
started with my son telling me about his
experience
of being a poll watcher in the november
3rd 2020 election in bedford new
hampshire
he explained to me that he overheard
voters state that their votes were not
being counted
when they put them in the voting machine
and upon hearing that he told an
official
that as far as he knew
nothing was ever done about it
in the new hampshire voter integrity
group i became the person who collected
the right to know data in the november
3rd 2020 election from all the towns in
belknap county
which includes alton barnstead belmont
center harbor guilford gilmington
laconia meredith new hampton samberton
and tilton
and attached to my testimony is what we
requested
what i found was data not available for
viewing in five days if they did not
send it by email to me and that is
against the law
i also found that several towns did not
know what certain forms that were being
asked for
and these are the elected officials
town clerks
working
i also found in laconia the voting
tabulator
tape of one of the warts
was barely
legible
due to the ink or fading
one town to this day after many emails
and phone calls to the town clerk and
the financial director
have not submitted
the town's financial data having to do
with election costs
from the year
another town did not have their official
moderator worksheets reconciling voters
and
votes and ballots casts
they also did not have the moderator
certificate
when asked where they were they said
that they had sent them to the state
in summary
there is a total lack
of transparency
in the voting system in this state
this state needs a full forensic audit
that looks at the entire
process
of voting
new hampshire voters need to have
integrity in the voting process again
i support house bill
1473 and ask that you pass this bill
thank you miss pitts i don't see any
questions from the committee
i'm karen thoman i'm from nashua
and a lot of
what i was going to bring up today is
already been said
and my concern is with the quality of
in the
city of nashua
it's
we have a huge problem with the same day
registrations
i say it's a problem because
thousands of people
we paid the city clerk for the new voter
checklist which i have one here from
ward two
uh that contains all the names and
addresses of the same day registrants
and typed them into excel sheets so we
could compare them
easily
people
that were registered in the wrong world
ward showed up in every single ward
so that meant the people doing the
registrations weren't checking the
street lists
and allowing just anybody to walk in and
register
people were registering from hotels
people regis a person registered from a
dentist office
on daniel webster highway
in a street that is so should be so
familiar to every single person in
nashua because it's taggart street
and that is where our big ice
factory is you know we get ice up down
there everybody knows taggart street
and they let this guy vote
so then we
we got
actually i went to city hall
because i wanted to verify a lot of the
absentee votes that were happening
and i had questions to the city clerk
which the response i got was
i'm not answering questions don't ask me
questions
if you want to come and view
the voter checklist for that day you can
come in and view it
so
i actually took pictures of every single
page
and i have thousands of pictures
stored
from every from all nine wards
there were
pages and pages
of i would
that that might be an exaggeration let's
say there was five pages
and during the pre-processing of
absentee ballots they got together in
the school gym
and they highlighted everybody that had
returned an absentee ballot so on
election day
all those people were highlighted
knowing that oh there's an absentee
ballot somewhere don't come in and vote
so they could tell them that you know we
already got it go home
there were there were at least five
pages
on the checklist in ward two
that
the process is
you you check the little check box
you cross out the name and then you
write av
for absentee vote in red
next to that entry
so there was all kinds of avs written
but never checked and never crossed out
is that a vote
can i i can't even go to my city clerk
and say are these votes because i'm not
allowed to ask questions
how do i verify this
there are so many things wrong that are
happening there it's
one by one they're little but add them
up and it's a
mountain the other thing i want to say
about the
the voting machines is
in nashua
we get together
we
everybody calls in they tell we tell
each other what the
count is
we went to taking pictures of the tapes
many years ago
because it was much easier to text a
picture
than to call and say numbers so i have
years we have years and years of
pictures of tapes
and the thing i noticed this year
was the download version of the software
on some of the machines is different
and that's a problem i think
something's wrong
okay
that's all i gotta say i i echo everyone
else here there's lots of things going
on in these towns
thank you does anybody have any
questions thank you for coming and
testifying
um
all right you're gonna yeah tip that up
so i think we're going to ask you to put
it down when you're down too because
nobody else will use it that high yeah
it's actually david cost invader but
that's okay
i've lived in new hampshire for nearly
30 years
i've worked in club management
and in sales and i love this state
the reason i volunteered to help canvas
is because i care about our country our
state
and most of all
my
grandchildren my father was a world war
ii fighter pilot in the pacific and a
lot of american blood was shed to
protect our freedom
and most importantly our sacred vote
upon learning that rye had something
like 120 percent of eligible voters
registered
120 percent of eligible voters
registered i had to see if this was true
so i spent some time knocking on doors
asking a few questions
did you vote in the 2020 presidential
election
i did not
want to know who they voted for but i
wanted to verify
that the voter logs were accurate
of the homes that i was able to contact
more than 10 percent of them had issues
i had a home on central avenue where
both husband and wife did not vote in
2020 elections
yet the official voter checklist showed
they voted absentee
they were in shock and they thanked me
for
helping to correct the situation
another home i visited had four people
voted absentee from that address
the problem is there's only one person
that lived there
there are even votes from property
addresses that didn't exist
in the town of rye how is this even
possible
the majority of both democrats and
republicans alike don't trust our
elections
you guys
can fix this
as you're probably aware lhs associates
is a privately owned company that
programs over 80 percent
of the new hampshire election
via their accubote dibol dominion
machines
lhs services these machines the
microchips and memory data cards
they operate independently without any
state oversight or audits by the state
of new hampshire the secretary of state
or the department of justice
the lhs technology in my town is over 20
years old
is this really the best we can do
so i went to see my local town clerk to
learn more she actually initially seemed
willing to help she showed me where the
accu vote machines were locked up in the
so so i went on to uh
she went on to state that these machines
were purchased before her arrival which
was
almost 18 years ago right
when i told my town clerk about all the
voter registration issues that i had
heard about in rice she said oh yeah
they've got all kinds of problems going
on in that town
i returned a few days later and asked
her if i could look at the activity logs
for the past three years for the canvas
bags
memory cards and microchip counting
devices
i also wanted a copy of the purchase
contract and service agreement for the
lhs dominion machine
i gave her this request in person on
december 21st
it was during the christmas holiday time
so she said give me a couple of weeks
and i'll get you all the information
so after two weeks i called her back
she's now telling me i'm going to be so
busy i can't get back to your request
for several months now
i'm just one citizen i have a right to
know law i want to see what's going on
in my town and i'm stonewalled
what can i do do i get to go to my
selectum do i come to you guys well i
don't even know where to go
i don't trust nor do i have any
confidence in the current voting system
why is there no post election audit in
it's because there's no legislation
directing any of our talents to do so
but this is where you guys can come in
and make a difference
you know you're in this hall
with these amazing people that have been
here and you guys
have the ability to install change
and i think you should take that
seriously
the only way to know what needs to be
fixed
is to do a statewide forensic audit
and to put in future safeguards so that
this monopoly on voting machine
programming does not continue to go
unchecked
or what i would personally like to see
is for us to get rid of all the machines
and go back to hand counting
that's what canada does great britain
france and
australia however i am concerned about
how the windham audit was conducted and
who was involved
i ask that you all support the proposed
house bill 1473 to restore confidence
in the people
you have nothing to lose and everything
to gain
we must
and you must restore voting integrity
thank you
thank you any questions
jill shaw jill shaw will be next
thanks
hi
thanks for letting me speak
he was supposed to put it down
there we go he was tall all right
okay thanks for letting me speak i'm
trish jorgensen i live in northfield new
hampshire i need you to get closer to
so a couple different things personal
experiences
i have a daughter who's in her 30s who
was running
with the 2020 election so i spent a lot
of time
standing out with her banner and
canvassing my neighborhoods different
things in my towns
that are local to me where she would be
i
did this
and
i realized that
the day of election i went to
she belongs to the town i reside in and
she also represents a ward in another
town
so
i go to both
polling places because or voting places
because i want to see and help her and
be present
as i'm doing this i'm watching the
citizens
who voted for all you all by the way so
you got here somehow and i would think
voter integrity matters to you as well
but
she
as i'm noticing the citizens they are
paying attention to the signs i'm
holding
and the party that she's
tagged to
and they're
coming out kind of gesturing or
commenting to me about
how they voted
both towns
so i go home that night after she gets
her results
and i say to my husband it was an 80 20
in our favor
mind you
i'm an independent voter have been my
whole life i've been voting since i was
18. i came off the mayflower
i have abraham lincoln as a descendant
i'm a descendant of abraham lincoln my i
can d.a.r all that stuff
voting matters
and it's what
our country stands behind
so
she wins the election but i tell my
i go and i pay attention to the numbers
as they come through and i take pictures
i still have them on my computer of the
different towns around me and how their
numbers looked
mind you my town has no machine
i'm grateful for that i don't think
machines should be but the ward where
she her other ward is does have machines
she still won and her numbers were good
out of that town but
it just kind of showed me
the
towns that were around me and what their
numbers looked like
to me it seemed a little odd
but
in some of these but i didn't you know
what am i going to do about it
so then
my daughter says mom
the committee
our county committee
you need to run
so
i said what do you mean ron what does it
entail i
have never done this before she'd never
been a representative before but she won
and she's one of you
and i'm grateful she's one of you but
she has integrity and she has a moral
code that i gave her and plants it in
her and i hope you all
have one too
so
she says mom you need to run for our
county committee i said okay what's it
entail and i proceed i had to write a
letter i had to interact with a couple
of the people that were in charge of the
committee and i joined and i ran and i
won
so now i'm part of the committee for the
republican
county
but
when i go to do this
i had been an independent voter prior to
i changed my party affiliation
on day of voting
and i did not go back like i always had
my whole life and i'm not a young person
so excuse me ms jorgensen a couple of
things one year at your time that i've
basically been giving everybody else so
if you can wrap up in about a minute
okay so so the republican committee
member whose head
calls me and tells me i'm not registered
as a
party
i said what do you mean i'm not
registered as a party
well in the state thing where you're
where we go look to see what you're
registered as
you're in you're not you're a democrat
i said
i've never voted democrat and i've
always been an independent voter my
husband's listed as an
independent voter but i'm listed as a
democrat in the state's
information
well how the hell did that happen
my daughter ran on the republican ticket
she's a republican state house rep
i am a republican and i had to go to my
town and my town clerk says to me i
remember that you didn't change back
after because of your daughter
this is my town we don't even use
machines
she knows me
so she so she says well we're gonna have
to change that
so i had to get in touch with the
moderators of the checklist in my town
they only work once a month or something
it took me three weeks to get it done
and i had to take pictures of that being
done so that i could send it to the
committee that i am now
on
to prove my affiliation it's ridiculous
there's so many things wrong with
elections in this state it's a simple
thing and i never have been a democrat
and shouldn't have ever been listed as
one
thank you if you could wrap up please
yeah i'm done i just think that you guys
need to
support anything with voter integrity
because there's a lot wrong here
all right thank you
um i'm going to be turning the meeting
over to the vice chair wayne mcdonald
who will conduct the rest of the hearing
with
about four minutes for each speaker
and then we have a few more bills to go
on and i i wanna i'll personally thank
you all for here and the committee will
be taking these bills up in executives
so um at this point jill shaw i think i
had you speaking next and i'm going to
hello thank you so much for having this
opportunity giving me this opportunity
to speak to you and i appreciate all
that you do i appreciate everyone in
here that you've come here to speak and
all the people who spoke before
i'm just so moved um and i just want to
say it's really things are really bad
when the people who want to be left
alone get involved
okay so i'm here to support
bill 1473 i got involved with the new
hampshire voter integrity group about
five and a half months ago i've been
working on my computer working with
files getting in really deep into these
lists
into these lists i've looked up
6879 total people
in a database
to find to try to verify their birth
find their birth years and
find their birth years verify their
addresses let me repeat the number again
6 6
total people and not just seeing them
once
okay what i did is when i went through
to check their birth years i found out
that they weren't at the address anymore
on the list i had the list of the
registered voters and so i made a note
you know moved to somewhere else moved
to move to massachusetts moved to oregon
moved to somewhere else in new hampshire
well then after a while i just forget
you know if you stayed in new hampshire
good for you okay but i kept a list of
who moved to the other states and then
one then i thought but i don't know that
these people voted so finally i got the
list of who actually voted so i went
back to the towns
went back to the list and looked it up
and more often than not i mean like 99
percent of the time i was finding
these people who moved voted from their
address
how did that happen
did their absentee vote get forwarded
should they be forwarded i don't know
did they fly back to new hampshire
because that's their mama's house and
they they stayed with their mom and
voted i don't know i'm not making any
accusations and there are a bunch of
people there are a bunch of people i
couldn't even find at all
so
then oh let me just say
when i got to somersworth
what i found was
the people who moved weren't there were
so many that weren't on the list anymore
and there was one person who had moved
to maine but when the whoever was
working the voting they wrote down new
hampshire driver's license number that
was the only time i saw that a record
was made that someone had used a new
hampshire driver's license after they
had moved to another state
and i mean it was just
so
what happened to these other people
i don't know i don't know but all in all
you know and then we got all these
people who moved 337 people moved to
massachusetts 213 people moved to maine
somehow they still voted maybe they
drove back but people moved to alaska
people moved to idaho
anyway i'm sorry to get so emotional i
mean this whole thing is so unnerving
but anyway let me just sum it up
6879 total people 1065
moved 244 plus i couldn't even find at
all
okay and when i say they moved i mean i
have i have a way of looking people up
and puts their current address and
address one address two address three
you know so just 10 is like 15 years
before eight years before there were
people who hadn't been in new hampshire
for that long and they're still on the
voting list that ain't right it just
doesn't sound right so even with me not
putting down everybody i couldn't find
it all it still comes up to like 20
of people
who the votes
surely should be in question because
they don't even live at their address
anymore they don't even live in new
hampshire anymore okay let me just say
they don't even live in new hampshire
anymore
so please please fix it for god's sake
for the sake of our country for the sake
of your children for the sake of
everyone who's died from
for freedom
i really beg you please consider this
bill and a serious forensic audit and
whatever laws need to be passed to make
the elections
honest
for everybody they need to be honest so
that the people's will is heard
thank you very much
the next person signed up to testify is
good afternoon my name is lynn briggs
and i'm from amherst new hampshire and
i'm going to testify to what i saw and
what i found and what i reported in the
general election
in amherst there are three dominion
accubote dibold machines
all owned programmed wiped and taken
care of by lhs who oh by the way takes
care of all the acuvote dibold dominion
there is one machine in the in the town
of amherst and the date on the top of
the tally tape says october 23rd
last time i checked
the election
was november third
to date nobody can explain that i have
pictures of it i have photographs of it
it has been given to a couple of
senators it has been been given to a
couple of lawyers
to date no one has explained it
there is no reason for it that alone
deserves an audit there is no excuse
oh we counted them early
i don't know any laws that say you can
count absentee votes or any votes early
the other two machines have the correct
date
but one out of the three machines has
double
the amount
of democrat votes it was explained to me
that they were all
democrat
absentee votes
so i went to the moderator
and he said
we put all those all those absentee
votes into that machine
well no you don't because i observed two
or three people walking the absentee
votes to whatever machine was available
so they would not inconvenience the
voters who were voting that day
which is the correct thing to do lie
number one
he then went on to explain that there
were absolutely double the amount of
democrat
absentee votes
again incorrect i and another friend
have personally gone through the
absentee vote list compared it to the
registered list and there is not double
all right moving on
um i would also like to know hey i've
had several towns come to me and ask you
know hey did you see this hey did you
see that can you explain it not i don't
know a lot about it i've just kind of
had it thrown on me and dumped on me and
i'm doing the best i can do
where is the contract between the state
and the towns that says that we the
citizens we the voters more importantly
we the taxpayers
continue
and will continue to pay for the
servicing the programming the paperwork
et cetera associated with the diebold
accuvote machines i can't find anywhere
the contract in any town
i can't find anywhere where we the
voters said we would accept this
that we would continue to vote for it or
we agreed with it
we have two people
in our town in amherst that were given
absentee ballots
democrat absentee ballots they are both
registered republican
too many mistakes being made whoops i'm
sorry here have another one
what happened to the two democrat
absentee ballots with their names on
them did they destroy them where are
they we don't know we can't find them we
have one person that we've investigated
on our own and they voted from
california
we have
400 and something same-day registrations
they have not been gone through the
secretary of state has not sent out
postcards letters or anything to find
out so we're going to have to canvas it
on our own
what do our tax dollars go for what are
we paying for
i don't know i'd like somebody to answer
that
the accuvoice die old dominion machines
were temporary when they first started
they've now been here 20-plus years
again when did we vote for them
when did we say we paid a service for
them and oh by the way who's the person
signing the check in every town to pay
lhs which is throughout new england okay
my last point is the u.s constitution
does not confer the right to vote it is
the state of new hampshire you must be
born here or naturalized here
i am an american citizen i was born in
washington d.c i can say that
most of you cannot most of you cannot
i became a natural naturalized citizen
in this state and i think that
the constitution of the state of new
hampshire must be followed at all costs
and not twisted and turned for whatever
anybody wants thank you
thank you
okay i also signed up to testify is
thank you mr chairman my name is alvin c
i live in loudoun new hampshire i'm
speaking for myself
on this particular bill
i'm very concerned that
because two election elections at least
one election has already happened after
the general election for which this
audit is for
either the town elections last spring or
the city elections last fall so this may
make it hard to
do a complete forensic analysis
however it is possible to do
a
hand recount of the three offices
specified in the bill
and that would certainly go a long way
to comparing it with what the machines
had reported
and from the previous testimony on this
bill
i think one other thing that needs to be
audited
voters
especially the absentee voters where
they voted from where they claimed they
resigned
and
also
any deceased voters who still manage to
turn in a ballot anyway
that is something worthy of of an audit
that's all i have for this bill thank
you thank you mr c
and the final speaker that i know of is
um
and i'm
having a little trouble reading the name
a brendino brandano
brendano okay
i have bad handwriting too
jose is better than mine i'm just not as
you indicated five minutes sir again
well asking people to try to keep it at
four yes sir first of all thank you very
much my name is al brandano i'm from
kensington new hampshire independent
voter for 33 years
i did a citizen audit in the town of
kensington and was honest to god
it's hard for me because i know all the
people there and the more i started to
look and the more we started to
find out in the policy and procedures
were totally off the rails
and it's interesting because i'm working
with the secretary of state and the
department of justice on just this issue
and one of the things that i found is
that
the town clerks
and the moderators don't have official
training there's no certification for
them they don't have to attend any
classes they do by choice but it's not
required
and if the fact that they don't have any
formal training and or audit the
secretary of state nor the department of
justice audits any of the policy and
procedures until there's an issue
so there's no
pre-preliminary look at anything
what i want to share with you more than
anything as i look around this room so
impressed by these people on the wall
and and with you you all have this
responsibility
human beings realize that there's truth
and trust as empirical or scientific
fear always drives one they choose first
fear leads to mistrust and this is the
most dangerous miscalculation of all
because trust is like a soap bubble once
it's gone it never really returns
we are well beyond the tipping point of
trust regardless of who you blame or why
it's really too late
so i share with you a line from the
bible to make my point
give unto caesar what is caesar's and
give unto god what is god
in today's words give unto the
politicians what is the politicians and
give unto the voters their sacred rights
of voting
when a politician takes this trust
it's called totalitarianism
be bold please be bold
do what is inherently human
and simple
the question before us is do we trust
lhs or which or do we trust our voters
do we trust the people in this room or
we trust lhs
i think you know the answer to that
please don't be the party of the person
to break the sacred bubble of trust
please vote to support this bill thank
you
thank you very much
okay i have no other pink cards for this
particular bill
so i am closing the hearing on this
legislation
on
and we are moving on to house bill 1467.
like to recognize representative
hello mr chair members of the committee
thanks for welcoming me me here i am
from hooksett
representing merrimack 24 michael
yakovich for the record
my bill
should be much simpler
it's
hopefully it helps
the concerns of the citizens it's a
it's more of a proactive build than a
reactive i don't know what to do with
the past necessarily but this is looking
for towards the future
and it does have to do with recounts so
whenever the recounts are requested at
the state level currently
all i'm asking here is to recount an
additional raise
so for instance um
if a state rep race is being recounted
the state rep for that district or for
the town can request
for the president to be recounted
or for
senator or the governor
anything that appears on the ballot is
fair game because we already present
those ballots we post them on the
display the
the
helpers
what are we called
whoever is looking at the ballots can
look at an additional column and tally
it up and that will give us a data point
for future use
this is not questioning anything in the
ballot necessarily this is just
collecting data points from that same
ballot that's already been pulled out of
the box brought into the secretary of
state office
is being looked at by everybody by both
parties
so i believe this information will give
us
something useful
when there are concerns
um will bring a little more transparency
into
the elections and
how the votes are tallied
so the recon
recount requests are not being affected
by this bill why the recounts are being
conducted is not affected how many
recounts there will be the reasons when
nothing nothing like that has changed
this is only when the recounts happen
uh this bill gives means to the
secretary of state and the requester to
conduct to
recount an additional race that already
appears on the ballot so i i view this
effort
as being very marginal so it'll it may
take a little bit more time to look at
each ballot because you need to tally up
an additional column but since
it's all there already in the room
everything
is set up
people are there in the room i think
this will be useful
to bring some more trust into the
elections
that's that's it thank you okay thank
you are you willing to take questions
yes please
any questions from committee members yes
representative barry it's it's good to
see you representative so just want to
clarify so this this bill because you
and i talked about this if i remember
right um so this bill basically while a
recount is happening let's say for state
rep right
we would look at another
office while doing that does it specify
which office we'll look at um it does it
gives a choice so the
so the choice is given to the secretary
of state thank you for the question so
the secretary of state
he he will pick one office and then the
requester of the recount like the state
rep
is able to pick another office if he is
so willing or he doesn't have to okay so
the the i'm sorry follow-ups
um so the so this the person being
recounted gets to pick an office and the
secretary of state gets to pick an
office there's two
two offices one one correct okay
so so the state rep hypothetically could
pick the president
if they wanted to yes they could pick
county commissioner
okay and the secretary of state's office
could pick any other office they want to
as well correct okay so it's up to two
officers so yeah
no more than two
any other questions from committee
members
also signed up to testify in this bill
thank you mr chairman members of
committee
my name is alvin c and i live in loudoun
new hampshire and i'm here to speak in
favor of this bill
a couple of things the
as the bill states on
line
six seven and eight the secretary of
state urs designee would select
one of five offices which are the top
five
so it'd be president
u.s senate u.s
representative governor or executive
council
that would be for all the ballots that
happened to be turned uh brought in for
all the recounts
the individual candidate who filed for a
recount
can ask for another office
that would be on the ballots within his
district not all the ballots just within
his recount
just as an example
after the
november elections in 2020
there were 16 recounts asked for
and
it affected
towns in seven counties a total of 55
towns and cities
so this gives us a
a reasonably
broad sample
but also since we don't know exactly
who's going to need to file for a
recount it's somewhat random it's not
perfectly random but i would say
somewhat random in
it
would
people involved to choose which offices
a day or more ahead of time so that the
secretary can prepare tally sheets and
whatever other materials are needed
so that they can do this in an
the intent was to do the recount and
audits simultaneously with recounts so
that
the ballots didn't have to be handled a
second time for any other reason
it just while the recount is being done
it does add a little bit of extra time
to read off extra names on the ballot
and and do the check marks on the tally
sheets
but i don't think it is as drastic as
what it appears to say in the fiscal
note
it will take a little bit more time yes
and that's pretty much what i have to
say on this
i did
[Music]
talk with secretary scanlon when he was
here earlier and asked him if he
had any opinion on this and he seemed to
be favorable to it but
there were a couple of details that he
thought might ought to be changed i
was sort of surprised that he didn't
stay to speak on the bill
and
that's not an official quotation from
him
okay
understood
so
just
as a
indication here there were
last time there were three state senate
districts
and 12
state representative districts and an
executive council
recount that was requested
so that covers a lot of the state
usually don't get a
executive council recount so
that probably would be a lower number
next time or other times
thank you
thank you mr c
okay i have no one else signed up to
testify on this bill is there anyone
i'm seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing on house bill 1467
and open the uh hearing on house bill
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative sweeney from our
committee
thank you mr chairman and thank you
house election law for hearing this i'll
be very brief this bill
is actually trying to form a commission
to have a real in-depth conversation
about how we structure our municipal
government here in new hampshire
comparing the data on how we see turnout
in elections at the city level versus
the town level
we currently have a number of abilities
within state statute that allow towns
using local control to determine how
they're structured the base level is
board of selectmen towns can then adopt
a town charter to keep a selectman
former government adopt a town council
with either a budgetary meeting or a
town council that sets the budget itself
or move into a city form of government
that either has a city council or a
board of aldermen
city charters or town charters control
the length of office individuals are
elected to serve in they determine when
the election dates are held if you're a
town government you can have an election
in march
april or may or you can move it to
november currently under state law uh if
you have two-year terms essentially or
four-year terms as long as your
town local election doesn't coincide
with the state elections
all of our cities typically have the
elections in november of the off year
for either two or four year term in
terms of nashua's mayor's office
in order to not have elections coincide
with the state elections that's all set
by statute this commission
my intent is to have a bipartisan open
public discussion
the the original bill had makeup with
three members of the house
representatives appointed by the speaker
three members of the state senate
appointed by the senate
three members of the commission would be
appointed by the governor
and three members of the commission will
be appointed by the secretary of state's
office in conversations with the new
hampshire municipal association
i have sent around an amendment that i
drafted to the bill that would add an
additional member that is a
representative of municipal government
uh appointed by the new hampshire
municipal association uh because there
really is i have no agenda with this
bill i want to have
over the course of the commission's
lifespan a real in-depth conversation
with a number of stakeholders from
across the spectrum
from cities from towns from everywhere
in new hampshire
to examine how the state structures our
municipal government and the election
calendar therein um so that is the the
honest and pure goal of the of the
commission i'm proposing i'm happy to
um uh yes of representative trojan
thank you mr chairman thanks
representative taking the question
so for clarification the structure in
the calendar um
is looking to achieve a
uniform
um calendar among cities and towns i'm
not quite clear on exactly what you hope
the commission will will ascertain i i'm
looking at the commission as not to
recommend a uniform structure or or any
of thing of the sort
i still strongly believe in local
control and i believe that local
community should have the ability to
determine what they can do under the
current law
what i'd like the commission to do and
what i think one thing it would be
tasked with per the per the provision is
to examine what are turnouts like in
city elections that are held in november
how does that compare to town elections
that take place largely in march
is there a way to make sure that across
the board we see you know higher
participation in our local elections
i think we all know it's no secret our
local elections are typically the lowest
turnout elections we have
um and i think having this commission
study how we we govern our laws and also
compare it to how states in the region
and across the country structure their
local elections and how they elect their
local governments and compare it to
their turnout and whatnot i think would
just be helpful to gather that
information and then any recommended
changes would be in the commission
report but allow all the data that the
commission collects and researches to be
out there for any legislator to take and
and run run a bill with on their own
thank you
okay thank you
uh yes representative thank you thank
you
representative
uh
is turnout that the number one problem
that this uh is that creates the
occasion for this are there other
problems or questions that you hope the
commission would look into so i i would
say genuinely generally
if you try to look up turnout numbers in
new hampshire you can easily find them
for state elections
because that's that all data is is
calculated and collected at the
secretary of state's website we don't
have a similar mechanism to track
turnout at local elections we could go
in town by down
but it certainly isn't simple but i'd
also want to look at the
uh incumbency rates at local levels how
often does somebody get reelected over
and over again what's their how does
that compare
for cities versus town if there's more
turnover
if there's less turnover how how that
produces it and really anything else the
any other questions from from committee
members for representative sweeney
okay seeing none thank you thank you
does anyone else want to testify on this
bill i have no pink cards indicating
that
anyone here in the hall want to testify
on
hb-1008
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing on hb1008
and open the public hearing on hb1082
and in doing so i'm going to recognize
the prime sponsor of this legislation
representative catherine pluto o'brien
hi i'm going to read to you um
what i wrote back in 2019 when this was
first presented
i still think it's a good bill it's the
same language and the same things apply
this bill ought to pass to preserve the
integrity and nonpartisan nature of the
offices of secretary of state and
treasurer
the two other states where these offices
are elected by their legislature have
either outlawed the practice of forming
political action committees for these
offices and that's in maine
or the creation of pacs to campaign for
these offices is considered by the
legislature to be so anti-anti-ethnic
it's a tough word to say out loud
anti-ethical to good governance that the
current secretary of state reports that
it would not be done and that current
secretary of state at that time was
trey haggart
now one of the things that came to my
notice
back in 2019 was
that
with the maine law
and i i wanted to get a little bit more
information because maine outlawed these
so i spoke to bruce peligwin who's you
might know him as the former congressman
from maine
but prior to that he was the main state
treasurer and even prior to that he was
in the pension management business
and when he was speaking to the
main state treasurer and this is back in
the mid 80s that man samuel shapiro
about pension management services when
shapiro told him he had a pack pelican
that he wanted peliquin to donate to
the pac was intended to help elect the
same state legislatures who would later
vote for him for state treasurer
peliquin told me his jaw nearly hit the
floor and he said it was the most
a lot a lot was was written about this
and spoken about this a few years ago
here in new hampshire because
we had a candidate for state
secretary of state who did raise a lot
of money
and when you
looked at how much money he raised in
his pack which i should say he
originally said he was going to use to
help elect democrats but then walked
that back
and you do the math on that
he raised about
twelve hundred dollars per
person in the legislature now in my town
we have ten state representatives
to his credit this man was pretty open
available to us and i got to talk to him
on the phone a few times at least once
that i recall and he he offered to come
to my community and talk to state
representatives that wanted to meet him
in person myself and another
state representative came and spoke to
him at a church
there were cookies there was coffee we
spoke for about an hour
but for the um the amount of money he
raised per capita you know by per capita
and i'm saying her 10 state
representatives in derry that cost
twelve thousand dollars now i don't care
if it's coming from
the canadian border it shouldn't and
those cookies they were they were
delicious but
that should not cost twelve thousand
dollars
to
he doesn't need the twelve thousand
dollars there's a point of time when
you're elected in november and then
there's organization day in december
anyone who's interested in being
secretary of state can call each and
every one of us each and every state
representative he can call us he doesn't
even have to meet with us in person that
would be nice but he doesn't have to do
so or she
so
i'm trying to head this off in the
future and i don't know what what the
money has been spent on since then the
the man raised about three hundred
thousand dollars to run for secretary of
state came pretty close to to winning
i have um
i also have a former state reporter this
was a bipartisan bill and a former state
representative from the seacoast area
bill's uh
jim splain
uh he
he was in favor of this as well and even
wrote an editorial and the
in-depth nh
that i would share with anyone and i did
back when i first brought this bill up
asking that this law be passed as well
so this is a bipartisan bill
the lead sponsor on it back in 2019 was
a democrat i just
wanted to bring it back quickly
in the second year and get this done so
i didn't go around looking for other uh
sponsors for for this bill but i'm sure
i could have found many of them and of
course again democrats as well as myself
so if i have if there are any questions
i'd be happy to do my best to answer
them
i see none representative so thank you
thank you
so many one of the hall who wants to
testify on this bill
besides representative o'brien
i have no received no pin cards so i am
going to close the public hearing on
house bill
and open the public hearing on house
bill 1242
and i recognize representative paul
bergeron from the committee we've had
three committee members sponsored bills
today representative o'brien
representative sweeney and
and now representative bergeron welcome
representative bergeron
thank you mr chairman
uh i'll be as brief as i can first of
all this bill would require that
it would change the timeline for the
charter amendment process the timeline
for the charter amendment process
was put into law
generally prior to federal requirements
that absentee ballots be
distributed 45 days prior to an election
and so this bill attempted to address
that so that if a community was holding
a special municipal election on the date
of the state primary the absentee
ballots for both the
municipal election in the state primary
election would be available 45 days
prior to the
to the election
i sponsored the bill after conversation
with the manchester city clerk and i
later learned
that over in the senate senate bill 423
sponsored by senators dallas andro
kavanaugh soucy and representative long
was also introduced and there's overlap
between that bill and and mine
so i would respectfully request that the
committee find house bill 1242 an
expedient to legislate and when the
senate bill cross is over we can take a
look at it at that time i see no reason
for the committee to be spending time
working on two bills okay so you do want
this you're recommending when we meet an
executive session we found itl correct
okay
all right thank you
okay um i don't know if you want to take
any questions at this point then
probably not probably there are none but
um
okay
all right
all right thank you um and since this
bill is um expected to be uh we will do
next media to legislate i'm assuming no
one is here to testify on it we have
received no pink cards so i will close
the public hearing on hb
1242.
those are all of the bills that were
noticed to the public for today
so i'm going to be uh i'm going to
adjourn the me this meeting of this
hearing of the election law committee
and um we will be resuming tomorrow on
other noticed bills thank you very much
is
you